si padece de hiperplasia benigna de
próstata
bp su glándula prostática está
ensanchada la próstata es una glándula
del tamaño de una nuez que poseen los
hombres se ubica justo debajo de la
vejiga y rodea la uretra el tubo
mediante el cual la orina y el semen
salen del cuerpo
y las vesículas seminales y la próstata
producen líquidos que se combinan con
las células del esperma para crear semen
durante la micción normal la orina fluye
desde la vejiga a través de parte de su
uretra hasta dentro de la próstata luego
a través del resto de la uretra para
abandonar el cuerpo
por motivos desconocidos la glándula
prostática puede agrandarse a medida que
envejece si padece la hiperplasia
benigna de próstata la próstata puede
volverse lo suficientemente grande como
para estrechar o bloquear la parte de la
uretra que la atraviesa como resultado
la glándula agrandada puede disminuir o
bloquear la salida del flujo de orina de
su cuerpo cuando orina
los síntomas de la hiperplasia benigna
de próstata incluyen micción frecuente o
necesidad de orinar en especial por la
noche
flujo de orina débil o interrumpido y
esfuerzo para orinar
con el tiempo la hiperplasia benigna de
próstata sin tratar podría provocar las
siguientes complicaciones incapacidad
para orinar daño en la vejiga y riñones
infecciones en la vejiga cálculos
vesicales y pérdidas de orina
denominadas incontinencia
si padece hiperplasia benigna de
próstata con síntomas leves o sin
síntomas posiblemente su médico les
recomiende una observación atenta que
incluye una revisión anual de la
próstata para asegurarse de que ni los
síntomas ni su salud están empeorando si
tiene síntomas moderados que le molestan
posiblemente el médico le recomiende
algún medicamento como los alfa
bloqueadores los alfa bloqueadores
relajan el tejido muscular en el cuello
de la vejiga y de la uretra para mejorar
el flujo urinario
y los inhibidores de las 5 alfa
reductasa también pueden mejorar el
flujo urinario por varios meses
reduciendo el tamaño de la próstata
posiblemente reciba una terapia de
combinación de ambos tipos de fármacos
si el medicamento no alivia sus síntomas
su médico podría recomendarle un
procedimiento quirúrgico denominado
resección transuretral de la próstata o
rtve durante este procedimiento su
cirujano le insertará un instrumento
denominado cistoscopio a través de la
uretra para llegar a la próstata
luego se inserta una herramienta de
cable denominada receptores copio a
través del cis tos copio para recortar
el tejido y ensanchar la uretra otras
variaciones mínimamente invasivas de
este tipo de procedimiento utilizan
láseres microondas ondas de radio o
energía eléctrica de herramientas
insertadas a través de las estos copia
para eliminar una parte o toda la
glándula prostática
si la próstata es muy grande su médico
podría recomendarle un procedimiento de
prostatectomía abierta en la
prostatectomía abierta
el cirujano hace una incisión en la
parte inferior del abdomen después de
dejar la próstata expuesta el cirujano
hace una incisión en su cápsula externa
a continuación se elimina el tejido
interno de su próstata y se cierra la
incisión de la cápsula con puntos
por último la incisión de la piel se
cierra con puntos o grapas
no puede evitar la hiperplasia benigna
de próstata pero los siguientes cambios
de estilo de vida harán que sus síntomas
sean más leves evite la medicación que
podría dificultarle aún más la micción
por ejemplo los antihistamínicos y
descongestivos deje de beber líquidos
unas horas antes de irse a dormir evite
beber alcohol o líquidos que contengan
cafeína
intenté vaciar su vejiga con la doble
micción para realizar una misión doble
orine espere unos minutos y luego
intenté orinar nuevamente